el humo se eleva sobre la franja de gasa
ataques israelíes en la madrugada del
jueves horas después de que varios
cohetes fueran disparados en la otra
dirección desde gaza hacia territorio
israelí fueron seis en total cinco de
los cuales fueron interceptados y el
otro cayó en una zona deshabitada
el catalizador de este intercambio de
misiles una incursión israelí el
miércoles que mató a más de 10
palestinos y dejó más de 100 heridos
miles de personas lloraron las muertes y
muchos salieron a la calle para expresar
su ira
las cosas se dirigen hacia una escalada
y esta ocupación racista y el gobierno
de extrema derecha están escalando
contra el pueblo palestino en nablus y
en todas sus organismos
no nos quedaremos de brazos cruzados y
el escenario de cisjordania y de toda
Palestina se transformará en un
escenario de confrontación con esta
brutal ocupación
la mortífera redada tuvo lugar el
miércoles en la ciudad de nablus en
sijordania las fuerzas israelíes afirman
que en un principio subjetivo eran
militares buscados pero cuando las
tropas se acercaron al presunto
escondite se produjo un tiroteo Se
confirmó que los sospechosos habían sido
neutralizados en la redada que también
causó varias víctimas civiles palestinas
entre ellos un hombre de 72 años y un
adolescente desde la olea de violencia
mortal que se produjo en Israel la
primavera pasada sus fuerzas armadas han
llevado a cabo incursiones casi diarias
en si Jordania